تركت جنان عالم المال والاعمال وانغمست
بين الطحين والعجين وخلفن المناقيش ازمات
لبنان المتتاليه دفعت بها الى تحقيق حلمها
ولو قبل الاوان فالمخبز كان مشروعا تدخله
لتقاعدها
28 سنه
لمرحله خلص يعني كنت مستلم الفرح حلو
الواحد يضل يتقدم بس بالنهايه القطاع
المصري كله نفس الشيء هلا لما كانت
الاوضاع منيحه حلو بيضل واحد يعمل ديبالا
مثل لحاله يتصور بس بس الاوضاعات ليه صار
كله نفس الشيء روتين وضغط الشغل ببطء
الشغل بينزل
[موسيقى]
نسوان الفرن مخبز يضم نساء فقط انطلاقا من
رغبه جنان بتحفيز المراه وتمكينها واحثها
على العمل والانتاج بس شوف الناس مبسوطين
بيجروا ياكلوا بفلوا لقمه طيبه بالعالم
مبسوطه بنبسط من قلبك المراه قبضاي بكل
شيء يعني بالمطبخ بالنظافه
النسوي بيقدروا يعملوا كتير
ايضا ردا على صوره النمطيه ارتبطت بالنساء
واعتبرتهن محبات لنقل الاخبار
[موسيقى]
لمنتجات جنان تعمل خاص مختلف
مناقشها معجونه بالتحدي والامل ومخبوزه مع
ابتسامه عريضه هي سر نجاحها
لصباح العربيه رينو
[موسيقى]